most of us just love a good film halation,
but it s pretty hard to understand how
to create the effect in such a way that is
rendering a natural and subtle halation bleeding
so in today s video I will show you exactly how I
cracked the best halation settings and how to
understand what each slider is actually doing
before we start, it took me quite some
time experimenting and testing hundred
of shoots to find these settings, so
why not hit the like button and share
the video with other people that
might need this in their workflow.
No more time wasting, let s get into davinci
Enter color tab by either pressing on it or
hitting hotkey shift 4 on windows, or cmd 4 on mac
In the upright corner hit the
effects menu and search for halation
drag it on top of the desired node and let s start
analyzing the first options we ll be working with
first thing, we have color space processing
you either leave it to your project timeline
input, or you can open and choose the
type of color space you have shot in
This particular video was shot on the
Cinechrome Sony Film Simulation Recipe
which uses a bt2020 color space, so
i ll just go ahead and choose bt2020
These sony film simulations are based off the
picture profile menu so if you are interested
n film simulations for sony cameras, go check
my website for the picture profile settings
back to the halation menu
You can leave the isolation
and the dye layer as they are for the moment,
and let s jump directly to the secondary glow
I will guide you through a couple adjustments
and afterwards I will explain what and why
bring up the strength
and lift the gamma all the way to the top
as you can see the halation is already
showing very strongly through the
image, so bring down the spread
it looks better, but the
colors are still very vibrant
the main problem here, the
secondary glow color is bright red,
Let s change the color of the
filter to a dark brown tone,
and that will solve most of our problems
so as a basic explanation, halation
takes place in areas of high contrast,
usually between sky and a dark shadow
so what i ve done here, is i ve boosted
the power and the contrast of the secondary
glow to make sure the halation will show up
even in areas of lower contrast, like between
branches, and reduced the spread to a minimum so
it s not bleeding all over, making it present
over the whole image but in very subtle way
I ve changed the initial color of
the halation which was very bright
and vibrant to a darker shade of orange
and that is meant to solve the color
brightness problem while also giving
a natural toned down halation effect
it s looking great already
some people like this kind of
look and they can stop here,
but for more natural and organic look let
s continue with a couple minor adjustments
In the dye layer reflection
bring down the strength just by a pinch
and you can bring up the gamma to increase
halation in areas of lower contrast,
but that s your choice
you can also adjust the spread
level even more to reduce or
increase the bleeding of the red halation effect
and there is also relative spread
which can be shown by checking this box
here you can balance out individual
color channels Red green and blue
favouring one over the other
will make it more dominant
we ll leave this for another video
next and final steps
in the isolation submenu,
set the threshold at your desired level, each clip
will require a different threshold level since
each clip will have a different highlight point
so adjust it to your own liking and depending
how much of the image you want
affected by the red halation
lastly film saturation, this
is again your personal choice,
but I would recommend going for
something subtle from 0.10 to 0.35
I have included these settings in my POWER
GRADE which is CALLED Cinerec 16mm film
print together with more refined color
adjustments that will give you authentic
film look, which can be used on any kind of
footage, rec709 or log, 10 bit or even 8bit
I ve tested it on the new arri alexa
35 cinema camera, and it looks great,
you can go check that video out, I
have put a link in the upright corner
If you like these settings, give this
video a like and share it with people
All my film packs come with multiple flavours
to give you more options to choose from
and you can find the power grades on my website,
go check it out, link in description down bellow
On my website you can also download the basic
node tree whch has my halation
settings in, or other free luts
So this is it for this video,
Till next time, have fun and take care!
cya